david cameron has said nothing in the
last three weeks
holed up at his oxford home as questions
mount
the prime minister who brought financier
lex greensill into the heart of
government
giving him a business card and secure
email account became mr green seals
lobbyist
after he left number 10 and as the
pandemic hit
tried to use his political connections
to help save the struggling company
wanting access to government coveted
financial support david cameron
contacted not just chancellor rishi
sunak
but two of his ministers economic
secretary john glenn
and financial secretary jesse norman it
didn't work green seal collapsed
putting tens of thousands of jobs at
risk we don't have mr cameron's messages
but on the third of april rishi sunak
responded hi
david thanks for your message i am stuck
back to back on calls but we'll try you
later this evening
and if it gets too late first thing
tomorrow best
rishi three weeks later he texted hi
david apologies for the delay i think
the proposals
in the end did require a change to the
market notice
but i have pushed the team to explore an
alternative with a bank
that might work no guarantees but the
bank are currently looking at it
and charles should be in touch best
rishi
sources here at the treasury say rishi
tunak received many more texts from
david cameron than the two
he sent back but the former prime
minister was able to lobby the
government
at its very highest levels and the
chancellor did go out of his way to help
even if ultimately greenville's requests
were rejected
ensures that the lobbying rules have got
to be radically improved
i'm also worried about what this shows
about our political fix
system where ex-ministers and ex-prime
ministers
expect well-paid plum jobs uh in the
private sector
and i do think this tarnishes our
political system
labor argue the chancellor may have
broken the ministerial code
we've seen some terrible examples during
this crisis of cronyism and the text
messages that we've seen this evening
raise far more questions
about whether he's acted properly the
only way that we'll get to understand
exactly what's going on
is with a full and transparent
investigation
for now there is no investigation into
david cameron he seems to be staying
silent
to avoid damaging his reputation yet
further
joe pike sky news westminster